I have a confession to make I have been
obsessed with weddings for as long as I
can remember
seriously I had a stack of bridal
magazines when I was 7 years old so by
the time I got that sparkly ring on my
finger I was a prime target for the 56th
billion dollar-a-year
wedding industrial complex which
surprise surprise wasn't exactly looking
out for our or our parents financial
health according to the Nazi early
survey the average cost of a 20-17
wedding in America was a whopping 33
thousand dollars not including the
honeymoon that's a dump
even on a house y'all you don't have to
be a wedding junkie like me to feel the
pressure to overspend and even
penny-pinchers quickly find their
wedding costs spiraling out of control
so how can you avoid your nuptials
turning into a mattre of money pit like
most good planning setting goals and
boundaries early is the key to success
[Music]
last year only 10% of couples paid for
their entire wedding on their own that
means for most people families help foot
the bill now family and money can be as
volatile a combo as matches and gasoline
so make sure you set some boundaries
early on have a frank and loving
discussion with anyone who might help
about how much they'll contribute and
what kind of say in the planning that
entitles them to before you take that
check from uncle Ted you should know
whether he thinks he'll get to pick the
menu how much money you'll be able to
put in depends on your financial
situation but make yourself one ironclad
promise no debt after years of working
with young couples I can't tell you how
many start off their lives together with
wedding debt shuffled around their
ankles incredibly 74 percent of couples
say they plan to go into debt to pay for
wedding costs guys I just I just can't
even don't get me wrong
weddings are important but unlike a
house or education they're not
investments so they're not something you
should go into debt for the IFTA sites
that 22 percent of marriages end in
divorce specifically due to financial
stress so spending more than you can
afford on your wedding may be actually
working against the very thing your
wedding is supposed to represent that's
way more ironic than rain on your
wedding day don't you think once you
know how much money you have to work
with it's time to start budgeting okay
let's see there's the cake the dress the
invites the save dates the food the
venue the entertainment the precious
handmade bow ties for the doggie ring
bearers the rings the favors the photos
the videos the flowers the ribbons the
chairs the minister the sari there's
virtually no end to the list of things
you could spend money on so do yourself
a favor and decide what three things are
most important to you and focus on them
for us it was the food the photos and
the music we promised ourselves we
wouldn't scrimp on those things but that
meant everything
was up for debate for instance you can't
go digital with your invites of course
it would be lovely to have hand-lettered
save-the-dates on a hundred pound acre
of shimmer wrap but why be Precious
about something that's gonna end up in
the garbage
we also ditch the favors I've seen too
many receptions where everyone just left
their heart-shaped cork coasters on the
tables and my personal favorite knock we
had a beautiful two-tier handmade cake
that served about 30 and Costco cakes
for the other hundred I didn't hear any
complaints hey if you can afford to go
all out on these items that's great but
on our budget it wasn't worth
compromising the things that we really
cared about you can also take respectful
advantage of your friends skills and
resources maybe you have a sibling who's
a baker an aunt who takes great photos
or a cousin who's a DJ actually I'm
pretty sure everyone has a cousin who's
a DJ asking for help in lieu of gifts is
a great way to cut costs and honor the
talents of the people close to you for
example my uncle happens to be a
world-class cellist and he was more than
happy to play for us of course remember
that relying on favors does mean that
you can't be as demanding or expect
professional-grade work if someone is a
hobbyist you may be listening to all
this in horror thinking how could I
possibly scrimp on any of these things
this is my special day I'm trying to
create a memorable experience well
you're not alone while the average guest
count is going down the amount spent per
guest has increased in spending on
custom guest entertainment more than
tripled most couples really want to give
their guests a truly memorable
experience but here's the thing most
wedding planners don't want you to know
people have poor memories practically
everything about your special day will
be forgotten sooner than you think uncle
Ted won't remember exactly what he had
for dinner
he'll just remember whether it was
served on time your high school friends
won't remember what kind of napkins the
drinks came with just whether they had
to pay for those drinks think about all
the weddings you've been to and what
details stuck with you having your first
glass of champagne a teary-eyed speech
by the best man grandma grandpa danced
to their favorite song
moments we remember the most often have
nothing to do with how much they cost
and that's our two cents
[Music]